he is a Democratic Senate candidate
against Lindsey Graham than the former
chair of the South Carolina Democratic
Party please welcome Jamie Harrison
Jamie
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so you're going up against Lindsey
Graham
you are well tomorrow logo or somewhere
it's very important because it's not
just Trump it's the Senate
those are his enablers and Lindsey
Graham and Mitch McConnell are the two
who I would say need to go the most so
what what is your strategy to get rid of
them well part of our strategy bill is
and you mentioned it earlier you know
there are a lot of voters who aren't
spending all the time watching MSNBC and
CNN or not and really voters when they
go in that voting booth sometimes they
find out about a candidate the day or
two before that but voters vote not just
with this but with this and with us much
more exactly right and so what we are
doing is we're building a campaign that
is focused on talking to the heart and
to the gut and we're also building a
campaign that is focused on helping
people which is a unique thing in
politics these days I lost a program
called Harrison helps it's the only one
in the in the country I guess as a
candidate and it's focused on going into
communities identifying the challenges
that they're having in those communities
and doing something unique helping them
so
and that's how I mean every politician
would say they're helping no but we're
actually helping so the first thing that
we did was a school supply strap you
know I grew onto US government's Reagan
used to say the nine most scary words in
the English language you're I'm from the
government and I'm here to help well
this is it that's what you have to get
past this is the thing I'm not from the
government I'm just a candidate running
for the government well I'm gonna help
them right now okay right there's a lot
of broken promises in politics and so
you get politicians who say well I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna do that I can't
make those promises I know there are
certain things I can do right now to
help folks I can help people learn how
to draft a resume I can help people
learn how to conduct themselves in a job
interview I can help first-time college
students fill out the FAFSA
there are things right now that are
obstacles to people to have having the
American dream that we can do right now
that doesn't take a whole lot of money
it just takes somebody that you elected
he helped me with my resume well the
problem is that you know sometimes those
people get caught in we as Democrats we
talk about the living wage and all these
other things my cousin told me once he
said Jamie
how can a brother just get a job
interview right mm-hmm
you know Donna earlier spoke about the
anxiety within these communities and
many times as a party we are talking on
this level and people just need some
plain English and tactics that
goalkeeping they are they run Columbo
so so you don't Lindsey Graham I mean
your [ __ ] I do I do and I used to have a
tremendous respect for Lindsey Graham
well so many people in South Carolina
did what happened you know that's a good
question
Lindsey Graham is you know I never
thought I would quote George will but
I'm gonna do so tonight George will call
Lindsey Graham a political windsock yes
this is a guy who is totally focused on
his own personal relevance he said that
I am so happy that the president allowed
me into his world this is the same guy
who called the president a race-baiting
xenophobic religious bigot right right
and so so in essence what has happened
is that right now Lindsey is only in
this for Lindsey when the people in
South Carolina are in desperate need for
help our hospitals are closing we have
had four rural hospitals that have
closed in the past seven years we got 41
communities in South Carolina who have
lead levels higher than the federal
standards so much is going on in that
state and Lindsey Graham hasn't been
back home in South Carolina in two years
to do a town hall but he's on Fox News
every night right because that's where
they see him
you